Speaker 1: I want to close out this story that
we've been following this week of Alex Jones
turning on Donald Trump with one final clip, which
is now just a straight up threat from Alex Jones
to Donald Trump. I'm not going to spend a ton
of time on the back story, but as a reminder,
Monday I played a clip for you from Christmas,
where Alex Jones did an emergency Christmas show
in which he said something he essentially turned
on Trump. He said Something's happened with Trump.
Trump is now pro-vaccine. Trump has always been
mildly pro-vaccine. But recently, Trump said
both to Bill O'Reilly and Candace Owens, the
vaccines are good. People who are vaccinated
are mostly not dying. The vaccines are good. Alex
Jones went nuts on Christmas and turned on Trump.
Yesterday, we looked at more clips of Alex
Jones really losing his mind and just obsessed
with Donald Trump over and over and over again.
Talking about Trump, Trump, Trump and vaccination
now is when it's starting to get
really interesting. Yesterday,
Alex Jones straight up started threatening
to spill dirt that he claims to have on
Donald Trump. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: We know Bill Gates is a
psychotic eugenicist piece of garbage. We know who
they are, but we're not going to share. And put up
with Josh Hawley or Ted Cruz or any of these
people. Wow. But Rand Paul, chief among them.
Yeah, we always try to do the right thing, but
listen, I got the inside baseball on Trump.
He doesn't know what's going on. I'm not
even defending Trump. I'm just saying we
need to move on. In fact, maybe you
know what to get Trump's attention
because I don't even get this from Roger Stone.
I get this from people directly in Trump's camp.
Speaker 1: He doesn't get it from stone.
Speaker 2: Remember that maybe I should
just dish all the dirt on. You know what you don't
want? I'm going to dish it all on Trump next hour.
I'm a go ahead and do that. And it's not to hurt
Trump. You know, people can know how pathetic he
is when you think he's playing 40 chess kind
of savior and he's not, he's not a bad guy.
But he doesn't know what he's doing,
and he still had about bad advisers.
And he's got that multibillion dollar social
media network based on Mastodon that they said
is an original program doesn't even work, and
there's all these sexy criminal investigations
of it right now, and it's all falling apart.
I wish Trump could go build a rail network.
I want to have success. I'm not against Trump.
But just like during the campaign, a year and
a half ago, I told you Trump's in trouble,
he's going to lose, they're going to steal it.
Here's how they're going to do it.
Speaker 1: OK, so ultimately he
did not dish any dirt, but this yet this is
delightful. And I have to tell you, I believe
Alex Jones does know some stuff about Trump.
I do actually believe he is a liar regularly,
but his contacts over the last five six years, you
go back to 2015, when Trump's campaign started.
I would be shocked if Jones didn't have some.
Up until now. Unknown dirt on Trump. Whether
he will actually spill it, we don't know. But
this civil war within the Trump community is
absolutely fantastic, partially because Democrats
seem to be completely ill equipped to actually win
anything in 2022. And we have to hope it's sort of
a pathetic position to be in. But to some degree,
we have to hope that Republicans damage themselves
will take a quick break and be right back.